Democratic nominee Joe Biden will appear
in his own TV Town Hall tomorrow night
he traveled to Florida yesterday holding
campaign stops on the first day of
Hispanic Heritage Month the Pew Research
Center says more than 3 million Latinos
are eligible to vote in Florida Ed
o'keef looks at what Biden is doing and
what he's saying to win them over Joe
Biden's first visit to the key
Battleground State of Florida this year
as the Democratic nominee included a
direct appeal to Latino voters Donald
Trump has failed the Hispanic community
time and time again Latinos make up one
in five voters in the Sunshine State one
of the biggest Battlegrounds where most
polls show Biden narrowly leading
president Trump but his Latino support
in Florida is lagging behind what
Hillary Clinton earned four years ago
and she still lost the state by slightly
more than one point in an interview with
notias tuno Biden acknowledged he's got
work to do I don't take anything for
granted I'm going to work very hard for
every single vote thank you thank you
the former vice president is expected to
win Latinos nationally but president
Trump is cutting into his Advantage by
wooing conservative Latinos in part by
warning about socialism a concern for
many Cuban and Venezuelan voters in
South Florida in many cases these people
are talking even Beyond socialism and
we're not going to let that happen
another challenge familiarity with Biden
poer Stephanie Valencia says many Latino
voters still don't know that much about
him they know that he was Barack Obama's
vice president for eight years but they
don't necessarily know what policies he
has authored or what his vision is and
so there's very basic work in which to
introduce him to the Latino community
that needs to continue to happen over
the next 50 days because anti-trump
sentiment is not going to be enough with
less than two weeks to go until the
presidential debate the first
presidential debate Biden says he's
studying up on things the president has
said and not said and he told reporters
last night he doesn't know who might
play the president in mock debate
Gail I'm sure they have somebody in mind
thank you very much Edo Keef the clock
is ticking to election day